[Musik]
1914 wurde hier heftig gekämpft,
aber auch siebzehn und achtzehn
bis zu einem gewissen Grad kann dies als
eine Art Pompeji aus dem Ersten Weltkrieg angesehen werden,
weil wir Sachen finden, die
zurückgelassen wurden und seit dem Ende nie wieder angerührt wurden
des Krieges haben wir dieses
Projekt als Crowdfunding-Projekt ins Leben gerufen,
weil wir ein Open-Source-
Archäologieprojekt sein wollten und
wir Leute für das Projekt begeistern wollten. Es macht Spaß,
der Mega-Spaß ist auch gesichert
eine Zeitmaschine und 100 Jahre zurück reisen
, das war schon immer das, was ich schon immer
tun wollte, wie Knochen auszugraben und
zu versuchen, sie zu identifizieren
Sie starben einen persönlichen Gegenstand
auf sehr unpersönliche Weise.
Wie fühlt es sich an, Nachbar einer solchen Grabungsseite zu sein
?  Tella, eine Sorge, die sie
für die Menschen in der Nähe der
Ausgrabungen eingesetzt hat. Sie wussten immer, dass
hier viel im Boden liegt, und einige von
ihnen sagten uns sogar, dass eine ganze Armee
im Boden begraben ist. Die
Leute in der Stadt verstehen nicht, dass
sie bauen können  Häuser darauf, das ist,
als würde man ein paar auf einem Friedhof
bebauen, aber ja, die
Politik entscheidet und die Leute
haben nichts dazu zu sagen. Ich fühle mich
mit diesen Leuten verbunden, vielen
Soldaten des Ersten Weltkriegs unmittelbar
nach dem Mons-Feldzug  waren Reservisten
in einer Position, die meiner nicht allzu unähnlich ist.
Ich versuche, mein Armeeleben nicht
zu sehr hineinzubringen, sonst weißt du, dass du
anfängst, dich im Grab zu sehen, und
es ist nicht so schön,
du